[Music]
steve's with us in montgomery alabama hi
steve welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave uh thank you so much for taking
my call
i've been listening to for so many years
and i finally hit rock bottom
and i need your help
okay
i'm i've been in the army now for 20
years
and i'm going to be retiring in two
years
and my family and i are in chapter 13
bankruptcy
when we were in washington state uh we
were full-time over the years
and we fell into buying a brand new
fifth wheel that was a hundred thousand
dollars and it ended up being a lemon
and because we're military and have
you know alabama driver's license organ
plates bonded in washington etc etc
a lawyer told me that lemon law wouldn't
work and our best thing was chapter 13.
so we're
21 months into our chapter 13
and we have
32 000 left in the bankruptcy
i have your surrender of the trailer
yes we surrendered it
okay but uh they missed the deadline
so they didn't get any money
so you surrender the trailer and there's
no
um
they missed the deadline to file in
under the chapter 13.
that's correct and
for any for any uh deficit on the
repossession i see
that's correct yes
all right so the 32 000 that's in the
chapter 13 is what
it's my wife's car
and my truck
and then four credit cards what do you
owe on the car in the truck
uh on the car
is 18
on my truck is nine
and then on each of the credit cards is
four
is not vehicles the rest of it's all
vehicles
that's correct so what's your household
income
so
gross is 90 000.
you know i'm active duty army and
everything and
and i have
you know i have i've just been horrible
with money i'm going to be perfectly
honest with you i've been a multi-tour
deployments
and you know money's huge while you're
deployed spend spend spend spend and
i've realized my mistakes
i'm sick and tired of living paycheck to
paycheck and just wondering where's the
money at
well thank you thank you for your
service and uh yes i appreciate that
you're appreciate you're ready to turn
this around
so yes sir
what you could do
is um do you have any money saved now
that you've been in this for 22 months
uh nothing at all okay all right
i would run a kelly blue book on both of
these cars and see what in this
ridiculous car market what they're
selling for
it's possible you could sell them for
enough to get out of them
okay
and if you did that
um you could voluntarily dismiss the
thirteen you would only have five
thousand dollars in debt left making
ninety thousand now we quickly gotta get
you a couple beater cars that you pay
cash for to drive around to get this
behind you but if you had two beater
cars that you paid a couple thousand
bucks each for right quick
you um
release this um
you you sell these cars yes sir and then
you you know dive in dive on the credit
cards and get them paid off i think
you're free and you're completely debt
free and you're ready to start your life
fresh and you're out of the bankruptcy
yes sir
but if the car the car the cars would
have to sell for enough to get you out
of them
right okay
they might sell for more
yeah they probably would down here in
this market because
what are the cars real quick while
you're talking to dave i wanna do some
research
yeah so the the truck
is a 2009 dodge ram 3500 that was used
to pull
the fifth wheel okay what's the car
and the car is a 2016 toyota rav4
um
it's the it's pretty high up on the the
options list yeah well i'm gonna i'm
gonna guess i'm gonna go even further
now
i'm gonna guess that when you look these
things up you can sell them for enough
to completely pay off all of your debt
and have a little money in your pocket
i'll bet you they bring more than 5 000
total than you owe
and then we got to get you a couple of
little dinky butt cars of some kind to
get around it for just a little while
but if you make 90 000 and you're on a
ramsay budget and we show you how to
handle money in financial peace
university and you don't have a payment
in the world
you're going to be just fine
you're going to quickly be able to get
better cars and pay cash for them
yes sir and that's that's what i want to
get to would you all would you and your
wife sacrifice these cars
i know that i would and i can i believe
i could
justify it to her because she's
she's
her entire she's taking on the entire
role of making the family function
financially and she does the lion's
share and i wonder how in the world she
does it she's tired um okay and she's so
here's what we're gonna do there's one
last thing you've got to do that i do
not know the answer to
and you you hear me clearly you have to
get the answer to this question
if you step out of this bankruptcy with
a voluntary dismissal
can the old fifth wheel company come
after you for the deficit then are you
stepping out from under the shield of
bankruptcy i'm not sure if they can or
not
if they could come after you for forty
thousand bucks because we suggest you
file
early voluntary dismissal on this
bankruptcy then you're not gonna do that
okay okay so you gotta make sure they
don't come around take your head off
after we take you out of this because
basically you have a force force field
around you called bankruptcy protecting
you
yes sir okay and if you let that force
field down
we don't want the fifth wheel people to
shoot at you okay
yes sir so i should i should talk to my
lawyer and talk to your lawyer and find
out if you file if you vo if you sell
the cars and voluntarily dismiss and get
out of the bankruptcy and clear up all
your debt does that leave the fifth
wheel people open to come after you i
don't know the answer to that question
i think it might
and that's what's scaring me
so uh what'd you find ken that uh you
got a 2016 toyota rav4 anywhere from a
hundred three thousand miles for twenty
thousand nine ninety or
one with eighty eight thousand miles
twenty four nine ninety i went a little
on the higher miles you get the uh i
didn't get them i didn't get the ram the
two more than it's more than 9 000. so
i'm right you're absolutely right they
can clear their bankruptcy completely by
selling these two cars and go get you a
couple of beaters
that's exactly what i do but not if
they're going to do this now hang on
kelly's going to sign you guys up for
financial peace university you and your
wife as our gift to say thank you for
your service and it's time for you to
change your life steve